what is up guys my name is jonah welcome
to episode 23 of 3d game programming in
java okay
so it's been a while i've left you guys
for one week i didn't post an episode
last week and
the reason for that is i am really busy
right now with schoolwork i'm fair i'm
not finishing but i'm starting my last
year of school and
it's really important that i i actually
do the work for school
which is why i won't have as much time
this year
as i did last year to post videos now
having said that i'm not going to say
that i'm just going to completely stop
like that's by no means what i mean
um i will be i will be still posting a
video
once a week as usual okay that's not
going to change
what is going to change is i'm extremely
busy for the next few weeks
with projects and assignments for school
so the deal is i'm going to teach you
guys how to make a gui
okay now in order for me to actually
progress on with the game engine that
requires me to sit down work out the
maths for that get
basically about three to five hours of
work done
for that and then i gotta i have to
record the video work out how i'm going
to explain
how everything works to you guys um edit
the video
render it and upload it which takes all
in all about 15 hours for one
i don't know 40 50 minute episode all
right 15 hours
i don't have that time anymore so what i
want to do is teach you guys something
that
you probably don't know but i know and
i've been doing this for a while
and this is also something that's been
requested
a lot okay so the thing that we're going
to do today and
probably over the next few weeks is
build um a menu
or more specifically actually first of
all a gui
a graphical user interface all right so
this is one of like the key things in
java like you want to make your own
applications in java
you need to know how to do this now a
lot of you probably don't okay
and or a lot of you do but you know how
to do it the complicated way all right
so the deal is first of all we're going
to make like a launcher so like you know
in skyrim or whatever there's like a
launcher first pops up and it gives you
the ability to change the graphical
settings you know options
help i don't know enable a mod or
something um
play the game exit straight from like a
launcher now as probably won't look as
good as skyrim's
but it'll just be a basic like a
launcher where you hit play to launch
the game
um and that'll be made with gui to look
like
a normal windows application um after we
finish that completely
we're going to move on to actually
creating an in-game graphical menu so
for those of you who actually want a
menu that's inside the game
or maybe you want both the launcher and
the game menu we'll create that after we
make the gui
and then hopefully by then i'll be free
enough to actually work out
you know stuff like collision and um you
know and basically
make progress on the actual game engine
itself and build up till we finish the
game so
this is basically me saying i'm not
gonna not post
videos for like four to five weeks i am
going to post videos but
instead of posting you know instead of
not posting videos i want to teach you
guys how to do this because you'll want
to know this
anyway so let's get uh let's get on with
it okay so
oh god there's a lot of talking i have
to grab a drink now
um we had this last time right and uh
we're not actually going to touch this
um this stuff now
what we're going to do is we're going to
jump into this um
i'll show you why thing so i don't have
time so this is going to be me basically
coding as fast as i can
our main method if you guys don't know
this then you probably shouldn't be
watching my tutorials you should be
watching the new bolsters or
reading the java manual i don't know
main method
is what gets this is what happens when
we run
our game it executes this code
so we basically what it's doing is it's
creating a frame and it's
uh it's it's adding the game content to
it and it's starting the game okay
that's cool
but we don't want to do that
let's um let's control x that so i'm
going to cut all of that
right i've just cut everything and i'm
just going to save that class as well
i'm going to make a new class in the
mind front package and i'm going to call
it
um launcher right again you can call
this whatever you like
and i'm going to make a um a constructor
for this class
and i'm going to make sure to spell
launcher right how do you spell osha
um and then i want to paste all that
code in there you can see that it sort
of automatically i
imported it now title i think we made
that static so we can just go display
our title
yep we can cool um because title
we made static so we can access it
from anywhere um and we still seem to be
getting a error and that's because
i didn't close the constructor properly
all right
so uh yeah so we basically just copied
and pasted that entire code
into launcher actually no i'm completely
wrong let's uh let's change his class
name to run game all right
now um if we change the class name we'll
have to
uh rename the compilation to it sorry
that was my bad completely
this isn't the launcher this is the
actual game so when we want to run the
game
this is the code that we need all right
um so yeah
so we basically just popped all this
code into run game
okay awesome now let's make a new
class and we'll call launcher this time
as we did last time
i'm sorry about that guys again i'm sort
of in a hurry and this is basically
where we're going to put
all of our all of our stuff so first of
all let's just make sure that
this is going to be our launch code
let's just make sure that it exchanged
it it extends jframe all right we don't
need to extend canvas
because this isn't going to be um this
isn't going to be like rendering
anything
so in other words we can just make it
extend um jframe let's import jfram as
well
um and let's make a um let's make a
constructor and
if you guys don't know how constructors
work you will after this tutorial i
guarantee you
um let's just uh do the basic things
like set title
to um to uh let's just call it mind
front
launcher um and notice how i'm not like
creating an object jframe i'm not going
you know jframe
jframe oh man i really can't start today
jframe frame equals new
jframe notice how i'm not doing that
that's because oh my god i really can't
type
um that's because we don't need to do
that because this extends jframe so that
means we can use
the methods directly we don't need to go
frame um
dot set title or anything we don't need
to do that so
if we weren't extending jframe then we
would you know it's the same thing we
did that in render as well
because this extends render we can you
know we can use width and height just as
if they were
well you know in here all right cool
let's get back to launcher um
let's actually close render 3d and
probably game as well um
okay so title what else we need to do we
need to set the size let's set the size
to new dimension
um that's a good size for the launcher
240 by 320 that's a good size for
launcher
uh by the way if you hit ctrl shift o
that'll automatically import
your your stuff so that's just a that's
just a uh i think so if you go like new
display
i actually know that'll automatically do
it during because um
we're in the same package don't worry
just wanted to show you guys uh control
shift o but obviously i'm not gonna do
that now
all right uh let's set the default close
operation to
um exit on close again we don't need to
go jframe dot exit on close because we
are extending jframe so you wouldn't go
jframe you could that won't get that
won't actually give you an error but
it's pointless
all right um uh let uh
let's set the location relative to oh my
look at that
seriously sorry i'm really tired right
now i just got back from a
convention all day i had to be there for
school
and i'm tired all right that's that's
the deal um so location relative to null
what else we need to do set visible
true set resizable as well um so visible
true set
resizable false all right
and that's pretty much that is pretty
much uh just about it all right cool
now let's talk about actually um making
our buttons okay so at the moment we've
got a launcher now let's check
let's check if it works let's just go
down into here
and just type new launcher
all right let's run that did that work
okay it worked awesome
um now notice again how i didn't go you
know like launcher
launcher equals new launcher now you
only need to do that and in fact if i
run this you'll see that it gives me the
exact same result
but the thing is you only need to
actually
create an object out of this class if
you're going to do something like
launcher dot i don't know draw
or whatever if you're going to actually
use a method inside launcher
then you need to create a um a variable
out of it but you don't if you if you're
not going to so if i just want to run
the constructor
which in this case is this i only need
to go
new launcher all right and that'll
create a new instant that'll instantiate
the launcher class which obviously
points down to its um
to its constructor all right cool i hope
you guys understand that
um okay awesome let's um
okay let's do a few things first of all
let's just get started with uh a method
to actually draw the buttons
so i'm gonna go private void uh draw
buttons
and um yeah okay cool let's talk about
buttons there are a few different ways
of doing this i want to
use a jpanel and j button to actually do
this stuff
this is in my experience probably the
easiest way to do this so let's just
make a new jpanel first because we need
a jpanel to store j buttons
um we'll call it window and we will uh
set it equal to new
jpanel and um
again ctrl shift o will import that for
you automatically so don't have to wait
for the mouse to you know
just do a stuff um and let's also create
a few j buttons so private j button
uh let's make a few let's call it play
um what else do we want in our menu
options
um
help maybe quit i don't know about um
mods i don't know like just
we'll we'll do these four for now again
let's import j buttons
and also i'm also going to go rectangle
private rectangle r play so i was going
to stand for rectangle and play is going
to be the play button
so for the play button for the options
button for the help button
and for the quit button all right
awesome
um now let's go into here and start
actually
initializing these variables now at the
moment this will sort of be a null
pointer exception
it's the same thing as if we did um i
don't know private double
we don't actually need private here but
double um we'll make a double called
uh i don't know p and and we just do
that you know we don't set it equal to
anything
it's not equaling zero you know it's
it's a null pointer it it's not pointing
it's got zero data assigned to it
so we actually need to assign data so
here we went window we didn't just go
window you know we didn't do that
we went window equals new j panel so we
set it equal to something
same thing we have to do for these
obviously otherwise we'll get a null
pointer exception if we try and use them
so let's start off with the play button
so play equals new
j button and the j button constructor
takes one parameter
and that is the actual title of the uh
thing so let's call play and we'll put
an explanation mark there to make it
cool
um and yeah so now what we need to do is
basically say okay we've got a button
now we have to position it on our screen
and um
and uh you know position it on our
screen and set a size to it basically
draw it onto our screen now before i do
that actually i'm showing you this
thinking why didn't i make these
variables let's go up the top
and uh we'll make um
yeah we'll make um we'll make uh to
make private uh
width so we'll make width equal to
private int width equal to i again i'm
really tired guys i'm sorry
um we'll make width and height and
height is 320
all right and we'll just make sure that
works out um
height god i really can't type all right
so we've got this awesome
um so
did i the hell did i delete that line i
didn't mean to okay awesome cut it back
i don't know what happened there
ctrl d seems to delete delete lines look
at that it eats them up
um anyway so we've got play now let's
also instantiate the
the rectangle for play so our play
equals new rectangle now there are a few
different constructors for rectangle
there's just this one which is like i
don't know why you would use that
actually i've never used that
in my life but uh there's also the um
the one with four parameters and that is
you know
like the x and y location the top of the
top left corner of the button of the
rectangle
and um and the width and the height of
the rectangle so let's just put a
rectangle
20 50 just to demonstrate um and how
wide should we make it buttons usually
80 by 40.
they're not usually 80 by 40 but 80 by
40 is a good size
um and now we need to actually assign
the boundaries of this
button to being this rectangle so play
dot set bounds is going to equal to
rectangle
and where is it i'll play awesome
now notice you could have also um set it
equal to you know 20 50
80 40. you could have just done it here
like you didn't actually need to create
a rectangle
um i just prefer to okay i like to sort
of keep myself organized
with rectangles that's just me you know
and finally let's actually add
window.add that button to our window now
before we actually draw that onto the
screen we actually need to initialize
this uh this jpanel we haven't made this
a jpanel yet
and the way we make this a jpanel is
first of all um
let's um let's go get content pane
and let's set that um let's add
the window so we've added a uh we've
added the
panel i guess um and also we need to uh
set the layout equal to uh we'll just
we'll just set it to null
all right cool so now let's launch this
and see if we get our button
okay we did not get our button that is
because i forgot to actually draw the
button so down here let's just go draw
buttons
and let's see if that works okay awesome
so we've got a button now
um it's working it doesn't do anything
it's just it's a button
all right cool simple simple old button
um now the other thing
the thing that i reckon most of you are
going to say right now is whoa dude
that's like a java button
like what happened to like my standard i
don't know windows buttons
like i want a button that looks like
this or like this like this or whatever
why does mine look like a java button
and that's no problem okay if you don't
like the style of java buttons and you
really want to make it look like a
window
like a windows button all you have to do
is go try
ui manager dot set look and feel
to ui manager dot
get system look and feel class name
all right and again you have to catch
that exception obviously just catch a
normal exception a
and we'll just print the stack right to
go to measure and that is it let's
launch it
oh look at that check it out we've got a
normal windows button now isn't that
amazing
yes it is all right one thing we
actually want to do at the moment is
probably
probably places in the middle now we
could actually finally you know work
out the actual middle of this or we
could just um
easily use math to work it out for us
first of all though i'm actually going
to make a few more integers i want to
make a button width
because i want all my buttons to be the
same size and if i want to resize them
you know i
want i just want them to assign i just
want to assign it to a variable because
that's good measure
again copy and paste that we'll call
this height and we'll set that equal to
40.
all right cool so let's replace 80
uh let's 80 with button width and 40
with one height
and um cool so let's so how do we work
out you know the middle of something
easily um
all we have to do is let's get the width
so with
uh divide by two we're gonna divide the
width of the actual
frame by two and we're gonna subtract
the button width away from that
so button width divide by two and uh if
my maths is correct and it usually is
uh you can see that this button is in
the middle of the
screen awesome um and
it's sort of 50 in the air we can just i
don't know we can put that to like 90 i
don't know that should be cool
yeah awesome so this is in the middle of
the screen now and it's
um it's 90. okay cool you can't actually
see that because of my uh
my dual screen it's called ultramod it's
really useful if you have multiple
monitors
let me just close that though you'll
probably see like all the stuff come up
to here now
my screen recorder yeah cool um so uh
let's debug the display yeah now you can
see it says mindfront launcher awesome
so we got play button
awesome so that's pretty much it like
that's that's pretty much all there is
to it let's
let's do the same for the remaining
three buttons let's just copy this
and one two three paste that three times
and just change this to
options
um let me just copy and paste that into
everywhere it needs to be copied and
pasted into
um including here and
here um what else do we have
help let's copy and paste help into
everywhere it needs to be
copied and pasted into oh help
and quit finally quit we need to copy
and paste quit into everywhere
huh i think that's about it oh yeah and
we obviously need to rename our buttons
so let's call this one options we'll
call this one
help and we'll call this one quit
okay awesome let's uh let's try and run
it and see what we get
oh crash okay interesting um what's the
null pointer exception
where help oh
there we go all right so we didn't
instantiate help we should have
my bad again i'm tired all right awesome
so now we got this with uh
uh all right again my bad the buttons
are all on top of each other
so let's um let's come here and oh how
what how wide are the buttons
um how high 40 okay so we'll just leave
10 pixels of padding and just
basically add 50 to this so
i've left a gap of 50 pixels between
each button
there we go awesome so now we've got
four awesome looking buttons
and we might actually add an image here
or something or a logo i don't know
we'll see we might make the background
black i don't know
we'll we'll figure something out guys
just post a comment if you want me to
stylize
it stylize this in a particular way like
put a video behind it i'm kidding that's
stupid um but
yeah and that is going to be the uh the
end of this tutorial
um again i don't have time next week
next sunday i'll show you guys how to
actually how to easily
add functionality to these buttons so
that when you hit play it's going to
close this window and open up our normal
game window
when you hit options it can open like a
new window help it'll open like a new
window and quit it'll actually just quit
out quit out of this launcher
so i'll show you guys how to add action
listeners and stuff like that but yeah i
have to go guys so that was
it um again if you want me to actually
add something to this launcher we will
be making an
in-game launcher in a future episode
okay we will be
but for now we're making a julia white
launcher um because they're really cool
but um a graphical menu will come later
but if there's anything you want me to
add to this
i don't know like in about i don't i
don't know just comment below and uh and
i'll see into it anyway guys that's
it i hope you enjoyed this tutorial and
i will see you guys next sunday
bye
you